can the conservatives lift the dark
clouds that hang over them in the
Manchester Merk the party that's
governed the UK for 13 years put on its
annual
Jamboree the task is sizable persuade a
disgruntled poorer country that it's the
conservatives that are the party of
change and keep civil wars that have
rocked the party in recent years from
exploding again when you have people who
just want very different things you have
a wing of the party believe in much
lower taxes a much smaller State uh some
people think the multiculturalism has
failed and you have other people in the
party the more moderate One Nation Wing
who are horrified by these pomin and do
see the need for more investment in
parts of the country that we were
promising to level up so when you have
such a wide range of views the prime
minister is effectively walking a
political tight road ahead of an assumed
general election next year rishy sunak
government has been offering red meat
policies supposed to appear yeld to a
core financially squeezed electorate so
it's scaled back green commitments and
low speed limits in cities and it's
sewing huge doubts over the future of
hs2 an expensive High-Speed Rail Project
that would link north and south are
these having any effects well the
conservatives are still significantly
behind the opposition labor party in the
polls but a couple of recent surveys
suggest that that Gap might be narrowing
changing more people's minds is of
course the main job between now and next
year's
election foreign secretary James
cleverly was one of the conference's
opening speakers let me spell it out to
the people who think our best years are
behind us and let me make it clear to
those on the labor benches who want to
play politics and put our country down
this government with rishy sunak at the
helm takes decisive measures and is
prepared to take the tough long-term
decisions for the benefit
of our
country but behind the displays of
determination there is much internal
grumbling conservatives complain in
WhatsApp groups that Rishi sunak isn't
up to the job and that their time is
probably up neither public opinion nor
history is on their side the Tories have
never won a fifth consecutive term in
office Rory chin Al jazer Manchester
UK make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from from Al
jazer